well let's continue to talk about
tonight's meaningful vote all the
build-up to a we've got a former press
secretary Dominick rabe with us now good
morning to you yeah very good thank you
and it's an interesting day it's
exciting it's frightening for some
people a lot of people nerves about
what's going to happen and the Prime
Minister's been issuing rallying
speeches and cries ahead of this and
she's basically been saying and that no
brexit is now more likely than No Deal
if MPs don't vote her plans through she
worked to do that I'm not going to
question her
tactics for trying to whip up support
for her deal that's quite right and
quite a proper no I don't think it's
right and in law because of the EU
withdrawal Act we'll leave on the 29th
of March unless there's legislation to
change it and that can't happen unless
the Prime Minister change her mind and
that was confirmed over the weekend by
the former president the Supreme Court
Lord Neuberger in an interview and it's
interesting because I'm just looking at
the possible outcomes for this vote
tonight and people are saying that these
plans are a move towards a softer brexit
along the lines of a Norway model and
why do you think that would be a bad
thing well if you look at Norway in the
model we lose control of something like
75 percent of our laws we don't take
control of our immigration at all that's
one of the supposed answers of this deal
as bad as it is and we wouldn't have an
independent free trade policy so I don't
think that that's going to be the right
answer for the country and it's not
clear that those countries in the EEA
would want us anyway that deal is
bespoke for them we're much bigger
economy we've got different needs
cabinet meeting this morning at around
9:30 what you want your breaks to tear
colleagues to be saying to the prime
minister at the moment because these are
the final moments before MPs head in to
vote the stakes are high second guess
what the cabinet individually will give
as advice the Prime Minister well I
would you like to say if you were still
in there what would you be saying this
morning I'd continue to give the advice
I faithfully given which is that we need
to be delivering brexit faithful to the
referenda which means taking back
control of our borders are those no
money I wouldn't throw our hands up in
the air and despair when this deal is I
expect gets voted down we should
continue to extend the arm a friend
to our new partners we want to continue
negotiations well I think we always want
to see cross-party approach but the one
thing above all is we're leaving the EU
in March of next year we can't allow
anyone to prostrate or veto that from
happening that was the mandate we had
biggest Democratic mandate in history we
must deliver on those promises okay
we've got some questions from viewers at
this door for you ere we opened up
Twitter let's take a look at some words
this is from Sergey 20 asks is a hard
Irish border an inevitable consequence
of a No Deal if not why not if there is
no border how do you prevent movement
across it lot of people we'd make clear
that we would not see a return to a hard
border the head of HMRC does the customs
said that we could continue to operate
with our Irish partners on on the South
without any need for any infrastructure
at the border the Irish have said the
same
so trust the experts trust what both the
UK and the Republic have said and I
don't think that in the spirit of unity
Brussels when push came to shove we'll
want to see would want to push in and
see a hard border bet it'll be appalling
for European unity and I don't think
even with all the darker swirling
Machiavellian forces in Brussels they're
actually when push comes to shove go to
force that on the Republic we would not
do it here okay and we put this question
to scarce armored actually and we'll put
it to you as well this Robin John
pillock never mind the MPs confidence in
the Prime Minister what about the UK
citizens confidence with Parliament now
that's the that's the general consensus
I'm getting on Twitter this morning is
that the people at home are thinking our
MPs going in there with my best
interests at heart today or are they
voting in line with a party in line with
their own interests how can you restore
confidence well look in terms of party
the divisions within the party show that
people aren't just going for tribal
loyalties but I think the number one
thing is that we had a referendum big
it's democratic mandate in history that
we've ever seen in our lifetimes and we
need to fulfil the promises the number
one thing that frustrates people is when
you don't keep your promises both labour
and the Conservatives went into the last
election saying we would give effect to
the referendum we would
leave the EU and we would leave the
single market we've got to be true to
those promises we've all made and this
is from Michael Riley when war both
labour and the Conservatives pull
together and deliver on the vote they
the vote was to leave as you quite
rightly pointed out if a vote was to
remain
I for one would accept it and move on
that's what a lot of people can't
understand is there's so much bickering
going on in there that has held up the
process there's been you know road bumps
the entire way why can't the two sides
come together to deliver on this and
then we can all get on with you know the
matter domestic matters I would love to
live in the political land of milk and
honey where there was consensus but this
has been a very divisive vote for every
political party and for the country at
large but you're absolutely right to say
that we've got to try and come together
and that's why I think the efforts to
try and derail or scupper brexit will be
so damaging to public trust in our
political system